since i hold that science exists solely in
the self-movement of the notion and sense
my view differs from and is in fact wholly
opposed to current ideas regarding the nature
and form of truth both those referred to above
and other peripheral aspects of them it seems
that any attempt to expound the system of
science from this point of view is unlikely
to be favorably received in the meantime i
can bear in mind that if at times the excellence
of plato's philosophy has been held to line
as scientifically valueless myths there have
also been times even times of ecstatic dreaming
when aristotle's philosophy was esteemed for
its speculative depth and plato's permanentes
surely the greatest artistic achievement of
the ancient dialectic was regarded as a true
disclosure and positive expression of the
divine life and times when despite the obscurity
generated by ecstasy this misunderstood ecstasy
was in fact supposed to be nothing else than
the pure notion furthermore what is really
excellent is what really is excellent in the
philosophy of our time takes its value to
lie in its scientific quality and even though
others take a different view it is in fact
only in virtue of its scientific character
that it exerts any influence hence i may hope
too that this attempt to vindicate science
for the notion and to expound it in this this
its proper element will succeed in winning
winning acceptance through the inner truth
of the subject matter we must hold to the
conviction that it is the nature of truth
to prevail when its time has come and then
it appears only when this time has come and
therefore never appears prematurely nor finds
a public not right to receive it also we must
accept that the individual needs that this
should be so in order to verify what is as
yet a matter for himself alone and to experience
the conviction which in the first place belongs
only to a particular individual as something
universally held but in this connection the
public must often be distinguished from those
who pose as its representatives and spokesmen
in many respects the attitude of the public
is quite different from even contrary to that
of these spokesmen whereas the public is inclined
good-naturedly to blame itself when a philosophical
work makes no appeal to it these others certain
of their own competence put all the blame
on the author the effect of such a work on
the public is more noiseless than the action
of these dead men when they bury their dead
the general level of insight now is altogether
more educated its curiosity more awake and
its judgment more swiftly reached so that
the feet of those who will carry you out are
already at the door but from this we must
often distinguish the more gradual effect
which corrects the attention exhorted by imposing
assurances and corrects to contemptuous censure
and gives some writers an audience only after
a time while others after a time have no audience
left
in this penultimate paragraph of the preface
number 71 hegel is once again situating his
own work his own project his own approach
in relation to the demands of his time but
also like i put here in relation to his predecessors
in in philosophy and he's calling our attention
to multiple ways of seeing the same thing
he's talking about the opportunist of the
historical moment that he is is inhabiting
and within which he is you know bringing together
all these various threads into one single
not necessarily harmonious isn't with without
any discordances but one single unified work
uh one single unified philosophy he's also
thinking a lot about the reception that this
work is likely to find and he's kind of heading
his critics off at the pass um it's it's a
good rhetorical trick actually to say oh you
know i know that you're going to say this
sort of thing about my work uh because you're
that kind of person and that's really not
something good in a way to get critics to
say no no i would never say that sort of thing
um so he's he's cautioning us here it's a
little tongue-in-cheek it's a little bit you
know manipulative in a way but he is actually
getting at something that that is quite real
so he says since i hold that science exists
solely in the self-movement of the notion
so i've got this right here the self development
the self movement um science consists solely
in that there's other things that are called
sciences that are scientific but they're not
science capital s this and shaft in the hegelian
sense if they're not fully self-aware of their
own development of their own relation to everything
else and that that's a problem for for quite
a quite a few modern sciences so he says my
view differs from and is in fact wholly opposed
to current ideas regarding the nature and
form of truth interestingly that sentence
remains true today the hegel is quite opposed
to a variety of different uh ideas current
ideas regarding the nature and form of truth
whether it's those in analytic philosophy
or those in other continental philosophy those
in you know american pragmatism those in in
you know various critiques those espoused
by different relativists different dogmatists
hegel is still kind of an odd bird out when
it comes to this sort of thing and he says
uh since my view differs from these other
current ideas it seems that any attempt to
expound the system of science from this point
of view is unlikely to be favorably received
now he you know as a side note he enjoyed
immense success for for quite some time lasting
all the way until his death in the uh you
know early part of the the 19th century i
mean he almost made it to the midpoint not
quite and if we look at the 19th century and
in philosophical development not so much in
england until around the turn of the century
but in certainly in germany also influencing
what was going on in italy influencing what
was going on in france and also influencing
what was going on in america since a lot of
american philosophy at a certain point started
to take its cue from what was going on in
german philosophy and they started sending
people over to germany to get graduate degrees
hegel is actually going to become quite an
important thinker and not just because people
are becoming hegelians in the sense of you
know just following the system and we need
to just fill in the gaps there there were
some right hegelians who were like that but
uh people found his dialectical philosophy
a very useful very powerful way of understanding
reality so he influences people ranging from
the saint louis hegelians to josiah royce
to victor kuzera to maurice blondell um and
you know the british hegelians as well he
influences a lot of people let me put it to
you this way he catches on so well at least
at a superficial level that he becomes the
guy the system to react against if we're talking
about the existentialists if we're talking
about british analytic philosophy they're
both reactions to hegelianism marxism is a
reaction against hegelianism from within turning
hegel on its head so you know any attempt
to expound the system of science from this
point of view unlikely to be favorably received
well he was he was not quite correct about
that but there are a lot of people who say
i just can't understand this hegel guy as
a matter of fact i used to have a uh german
philosophy professor when i was an undergraduate
who said when i when i have insomnia i just
get out my hegel and i start reading that
and pretty soon i've fallen right asleep because
i can't make any sense of it and it just kind
of lulls me into uh sombolance so he says
here's how i can console myself there's been
previous scientific philosophy not as fully
developed as what i'm doing but there have
been other people doing things like this along
the way and it gives the example of plato
and aristotle he says i can bear in mind that
if at times the excellence of plato's philosophy
has been held to line his scientifically valueless
myths it's taken a pretty strong stance on
plato there there have also been times even
called times of a static dreaming when aristotle's
philosophy was esteemed for its speculative
death hegel really does take quite a bit from
aristotle including his you know notion of
causality is the four causes but the notion
of causality is we can always find some sort
of reasoning process that we can make sense
of even in what appears to be merely random
events you know in aristotle's term um there
are there are causalities at work they're
just complex causalities he also you know
takes the notion of teleology full bore from
aristotle teleology introduces notions of
perfection of moving towards some sort of
end or goal of organisms as being these collections
of processes that are brought under one sort
of unifying
being a unifying node in it some of this is
mediated a bit through leibniz you might say
and he says plato's parmenides here hegel
says surely the greatest artistic achievement
of the ancient dialectic interesting thing
to say isn't it which of plato's works is
hegel focusing on the most it's not the republic
it's not the symposium it's not some of the
others that people take as being sort of the
high point um you know who are the who are
the ones that the plato aficiondos really
latch on to well you know if you're injured
rhetoric the gorgeous or the phaedrus fado
the sophist no it's the parmenides why because
the permanentes actually shows a dialectic
at work he says it was regarded these were
regarded as the true disclosure and positive
expression of what a philosophy no of the
divine life of what was best of what was greatest
what was most real and times when despite
obscurity generated by ecstasy this misunderstood
ecstasy was in fact supposed to be nothing
other than the pure notion that's the the
low point that's possible right so he says
what is really excellent in the philosophy
of our time takes its value to lie in its
scientific quality even though others take
a different view it's in fact only in virtue
of its scientific character that it exerts
any influence now why is that
you have a variety of different viewpoints
in modernity that you can take on and and
think about and look at why pay attention
to any given one of them over others it could
be because it appeals to your emotions your
sound common sense could be that it's what
you're familiar with what you're comfortable
with or it could because it actually works
because it act it's tied in with the way things
truly are or it's closer to the way things
truly are and it gives you handles by which
you can make sense of things and we're not
just talking about sort of application of
technology you know understand in order to
control you know the modern scientific viewpoint
on on on physical reality we're also talking
about the self we're also talking about the
person we're also talking about society at
large we're talking about how we make sense
of our past how we make sense of our current
possibilities in our future does a philosophy
provide us with something that works that
is useful in those circumstances if it does
according to hegel it's going to be because
it has some sort of scientific in the the
sense that he means scientific scientific
basis it's going to exert its influence that
way so he says i may hope too that this attempt
to vindicate science for the notion and to
expound in its proper element will succeed
in winning acceptance through the inner truth
of its subject matter what's the proof of
of the the phenomenology going through it
and seeing that his analyses are actually
on track hegel is willing to actually lay
it all on the table and engage in one big
bet and say if you go through this and you
find that it's all garbage or you find that
it's half garbage then i didn't do my job
then i wasn't really doing science this raises
some interesting questions because you know
for somebody like me who doesn't actually
agree with all of hegel's analyses in here
um what what do we make of hegel do we say
that well hegel you know threw it all on the
table and engaged in one big stake it all
goes down or it all goes up or do we say i
think we have to be a bit more selective about
what we say he got right and what we think
he got wrong or didn't didn't go far enough
with or didn't adequately develop what he
dismissed too much from the past so he says
i want to win acceptance through the inner
truth of the subject matter when i'm talking
about self-consciousness i want to convince
you for science that this is actually the
right account of the development of self-consciousness
and what's at the very basis of it by showing
you the self-development of the notion by
carrying out a phenomenology not a phenomenology
just a you know external experience but a
phenomenology of historical development the
development of consciousness likewise when
it comes to observing reason or art or religion
or morality or any of these other things i
want to show you by carrying out the work
what's really going on with these in the self
to self movement of the notion so he says
um we must hold to the conviction it's of
the nature of truth to prevail when its time
has come another really interesting idea what
does it mean for truth to have a time that's
come isn't truth eternal isn't truth always
in existence if something is true now it was
true back then is hegel actually throwing
himself into a kind of relativism a kind of
what we call historicism things things are
true now but they weren't true back then because
because truth varies from area to era or culture
to culture no hegel is saying um you know
when it comes to certain truths humanity is
just not ready for them and he's not doing
this like agnostic i am one of the knowers
the rest of you you're not in on the secret
or a conspiracy theorist or anything like
that because remember the the proof of this
is that you can get other reasonable people
not just other people in your conspiracy to
say yeah i think you're right i think we're
on the right track we can be part of a community
of inquiry
is it possible that there are times that are
not ready for certain truths you know a lot
of people like well the other dark ages great
example they were they were burning witches
and you know engaging in all this sort of
stuff first off the dark ages in the middle
ages weren't quite as dark as a lot of people
make them out to be if you read some of the
authors from that time you realize that they
actually held on to quite a bit of ancient
civilization and they were doing a lot of
thinking at that time our little movie portrayals
and history channel uh caricatures at that
time are actually dead off the witch burning
took place actually much laters when when
that sort of thing caught on and that wasn't
something that was just tied in with a anti-scientific
viewpoint there were a lot of other factors
going on and if you were going to take a hegelian
perspective on that sort of thing it would
require getting your fingers into the tissues
of the past and reading these people and thinking
what was actually happening at these times
but were there certain truths that weren't
available for that here's one example
for hegel freedom is something that develops
over time and so he he talks about the importance
of in his view luther and the protestant reformation
he contrasts the ancient period which was
you know mainly aristocracies and tyrannies
there were democracies but they quickly degenerated
as teaching us the lesson that one man can
be free one person can be free the middle
ages showing us that um some people can be
free and modernity is showing us that all
can be free that doesn't mean that all are
free or all will be free it can be that that's
a potential that it's it's possible so these
are truths that that have to wait for the
right time to come the truth that philosophy
is really supposed to be science is really
supposed to be dialectical development of
the notion knowing itself through time et
cetera et cetera et cetera you know the hegelian
schtick that's not a truth that was available
in the time of descartes or in the time of
thomas aquinas or in the time of saint augustine
or in the time of of plato but it is a truth
that's available coming on the heels of kant
although kant himself wasn't wasn't quite
ready for it um and hegel is the right guy
at the right time in the right place to make
sense of it to articulate it for us and to
not i don't say boil it down but provide us
its outlines here in this massive dense tone
that we're going to be working our way through
that's what he's talking about here in the
preface that's what he wants to end uh or
come close to ending the preface by talking
about the it is it's now time for this sort
of project to be carried out he's saying so
he says um we must accept we must hold to
the conviction it's the nature of truth to
prevail when it's time has come it appears
only when the time has come and will never
appear prematurely nor find the public as
i've got this term public here not ripe to
receive it you can't have a lone genius hegel
rejects that that term genius by the way he
thinks totally un you know unhelpful in these
sort of respects you can't just be the lone
sage up on the hill this is written for a
public this is written for not a reader but
a readership it's supposed to be providing
outlines that other people can take and use
and go further with much the way aristotle's
books work much the way plato's dialogues
were so he says
we must accept that the individual needs that
this should be so in order to verify what
is yet a matter for him alone and to experience
the conviction which in the first place belongs
only to a particular individual as something
universally held so when these new truths
come on the scene people have to try them
on and live them out and they have to do that
as individuals they are going to be different
than those in the rest of their society sometimes
even as representing you know the highest
that's available in their society but they're
going to be at odds with many others and they
are not necessarily going to find their friends
their their readership their appreciators
in their own lifetime but what they're tending
towards is a universal community this text
is written for that universal community which
hegel thinks is in the process of development
it has to be lived out individually first
there's a guy hegel who has to actually be
at the nexus of this and try to you know have
as little bit of himself involved in it as
possible and just try to be sort of a vessel
for world spirit in his case
which i think he did a pretty good job with
but it's ultimately heading towards something
that's not just a bunch of clones of hegel
not just a bunch of repeaters of hegel's words
and thoughts but those who carry out a conversation
and ongoing continuing to develop conversation
hegelians so he says in this connection he
wants to give us a warning here the public
the attitude of the public is quite different
from even contrary to um those who are its
representatives and spokesman now who are
the representatives and spokespeople of the
public the intelligentsia the in our case
um the the political class um the people in
the universities i suppose probably not most
of them just you know you have more weight
the higher tier you are um the uh people get
invited to ted talks you know would be among
that as well for hagel hegel would probably
hate ted talks by the way there's a whole
conversation we could have about that
but yeah that's kind of an interesting digression
to think about perhaps i'll blog about that
who else the the elites the the people who
claim to form public opinion the people who
are opinion leaders thought leaders hegel
would say most of those people are full of
it they don't know what they're talking about
any more than they did in plato's time any
more than when socrates was saying these are
my older accusers the people who when i questioned
they couldn't actually say anything coherent
about what it was that i was asking them the
things that they're supposed to know about
it's the same way in our own time only the
faces have changed the titles have changed
and there's an awful lot more of them but
hegel's writing not to them but to the public
that he has in mind and he says the public
is inclined good naturally to blame itself
when a philosophical work makes no appeal
to it when the public reads hegel's phenomenology
and they don't make a lot of sense out of
it they don't say oh crappy work i couldn't
understand it so it must be garbage they say
oh i wish i could i wish i could understand
this i wish i was up to it i you know i read
through it and all this jargon i just don't
have the background for this it's a question
of actually putting the tools in the public's
hand that's part of what i'm trying to do
with these videos by the way putting the tools
in the public's hand to be able to make their
way through this and appreciate it and i'm
really you know i think that it's a good thing
to do so is hegel with descartes with heidegger
with uh you know pick whoever you want who
is an important thinker the public is is inclined
to express a certain sort of humility and
say yeah i understand this is important stuff
but i'm just not up to it that you can do
something with that is docility that's being
able to be taught that's what docility means
it comes from dokori to teach
what about the public what about the public
opinion uh you know representatives and spokespeople
when they look at a work s hegel says they
are certain of their own competence they put
all the blame on the author when they don't
understand it
so they've already got sort of a not only
a point of view staked out but they believe
that there are the arbiters they believe that
if it doesn't make sense to them it doesn't
make sense at all this is a certain kind of
foolishness it's not just a certain kind of
pride and arrogance it's a certain kind of
foolishness to think that because one doesn't
understand something there's nothing there
to be understood this is something by the
way that plato and aristotle both talked quite
a bit about you know aristotle says there
are some things that are that are in themselves
most self-evident that doesn't mean they're
self-evident to us because we have to do some
work to get there and if we don't do the work
if we judge everything from our standpoint
we won't see the way that things really are
in themselves and the structure that they
have the connection that they have to each
other
anselm actually talks about that he says nothing
is more foolish than somebody who thinks that
simply because they don't understand something
it can't possibly be the case and yet we see
that as a criterion appealed to just as much
in our own time as we do in hegel's time so
he says the effect of such a work on the public
is more noiseless than the action of these
dead men when they bury their dead general
level of insight we're at a particularly opportune
time hegel thinks is now altogether more educated
its curiosity more awake its judgment more
swiftly reached so that the feet of all those
who will carry you are out are already at
the door but from this we must all often distinguish
the more gradual effect which corrects the
attention extorted by imposing assurances
and corrects to contemptuous censure coming
from these guys right and gives some writers
an audience only after a time while others
have no audience left there there are many
people in the history of philosophy who are
only read by specialists uh in part because
they're only worth reading by specialists
people who are really interested in that time
period or needed something to to write as
an article for themselves to carve out there's
a lot of people who you don't you don't frankly
you don't need to spend any time with because
your time is limited and you have to ask yourself
should i spend it with these guys or should
i spend it with [__] or should i spend
it with plato or should i spend it with you
know if you want to pick a contemporary aleister
mcintyre um or you know somebody else that
i might get something out of somebody who
from whom i'll come away with having learned
something something important so hegel's saying
look my project you know this is complicated
stuff this is this is going to take some some
work to appreciate um if you feel that you're
not up to it i will help you along the way
i'm giving you the outlines of it it's it
takes some work but if you're the public that's
fine these guys over here are going to take
a look at my work and say this is not any
good we don't don't they're going to say to
the public don't spend time on this this this
joker because he doesn't make any sense and
you know he's violating the law of non-contradiction
and and dispensing with all philosophical
rigor not realizing that he's expressing a
higher rigor and he's saying that that's probably
where my time currently is as it turns out
like i said hegel is wrong about that um he
catches on uh quite well and keeps going on
like gangbusters for decades after his death
and then is is greatly eclipsed uh until the
early 20th century when he's again recovered
and people start taking him quite seriously
again but he's saying that now it's the time
for the issue to be decided whether he's right
or wrong about his reception um he is right
about what is going on in his reception and
what it has to tell us about the nature of
the public the nature of the elites and the
nature of philosophy itself
for the rest at a time when the universality
of spirit has gathered such strength and the
singular detail as is fitting has become correspondingly
less important when to that universal aspect
claims and holds onto the whole range of the
wealth that has developed the share and the
total work of spirit which falls to the individual
can only be very small because of this the
individual must all the more forget himself
as the nature of science implies and requires
of course he must make of himself and achieve
what he can but less must be demanded of him
just as he in turn can expect less of himself
and may demand less for himself
in section 72 hegel is bringing the preface
to the phenomenology to a close it's a very
short section he's actually not saying an
awful lot in that section that's particularly
memorable because of you know well phrased
uh lapidary sentences that we we bring up
like the patience and the labor of the negative
but it is important and what we want to ask
ourselves so this is the end of the preface
this is the end of sort of here's what i'm
doing in this work here's how i want you to
think about it here's all the different traps
that you can fall into is this really now
the start of the work as such you might say
well it's got to be because we've been doing
all this preliminary stuff up until this time
but notice what's going to happen after this
he's immediately following the preface with
an introduction an inferring which is important
he's going to start treating some of these
issues now that he's put on the table in a
little bit more rigorous a little bit deeper
fashion and then he's going to start looking
at consciousness and then the grand march
of spirit begins now one of the things that
he does close with this is very interesting
because you can see here just precisely what
it is say that the existentialists are reacting
against in reacting against hegel he's asking
what's the role of the individual i capitalized
it he doesn't capitalize it or the translator
doesn't rather what is the the role of the
individual in this well notice he's saying
this is a time when the universality of spirit
has gathered such strength we're at an opportune
time in history because we do have a a growing
you know widening better and better educated
more literate more thoughtful public he's
writing this by the way at the time of the
napoleonic wars when europe is becoming possibly
one giant state we're right we're at a time
in the universality spirit has gathered such
strength and the singular detail has become
less important the singular node within the
whole system the whole matrix has become less
important than seeing the big picture
he says when that it's fitting
that universal aspect claims and holds on
to the whole range of the wealth that's developed
the share in the total work of spirit which
falls to the individual can only be very small
so the individual here's again where hegel
is going to you either love him or hate him
you're going to to see this as as you know
his decisive turning point to what what's
you know most on track or where he goes most
wrong the individual fits into the system
and their their role matters because of its
participation within it's enmeshing within
the system of other individuals so he says
because of this the individual must all the
more forget himself if you want to understand
the hegelian perspective it's sort of like
stargazing you know if you want to stargaze
you look at the sky and you gotta like relax
a bit and quit thinking about did i leave
the the toaster on you know or what am i doing
next week or stuff like that and just look
at the stars and see this totality you don't
sit there and say one two three you know or
um just look for the constellations ah hi
from the big dipper oh there's scorpio no
you you you let yourself you let the phenomenon
impinge upon you hegel saying that when it
comes to this this scientific aspect of things
you know a community of inquiry that's how
we need to do it does that mean we all become
worker drones uh no because there's a certain
kind of freedom involved in this and not a
not a you know mere necessity but he says
that the individual must forget himself as
the nature of science implies and requires
of course he must make of himself and achieve
what he can that's that's not to say that
you know we just take our cues entirely from
the system we still require some individual
initiative some enterprise some willingness
to jump in you have to apply your own brains
and develop your own will but you're doing
it within a context he says less must be demanded
of him just as he can in turn expect less
of himself and may demand less for himself
one way of seeing this is despite the fact
that we have something like an intellectual
hero and you know a great work here in the
phenomenology and then to follow that it's
going to be the science of logic all these
brilliant lectures that he's going to do finally
you know the philosophy of right the encyclopedia
logic
hegel saying the time of heroes intellectual
heroes is drawing to a close we don't need
them anymore what we need is the system what
we need is the patience to work through this
to make sense of it so that's how he's ending
the preface to the phenomenology not on a
bombastic note but fairly quietly in an unassuming
way inviting us to take part in reading the
rest of this this great work so um i'll say
just a few things now that this portion of
the lecture is over if you've been watching
all of these that's really great this is a
like i said at the beginning this is a work
that i am i'm you know very excited to to
speak about i'm probably not the uh the best
person to to do these videos but i'm the only
person actually doing it so you know although
they're greater much brighter and much more
versed hegel commentators than i am um i'm
the one who actually was was crazy enough
to take on this task i hope that you'll stick
with this i hope that you're in not only enjoying
these lectures but that it's helping you to
go to the text i don't particularly care if
you're using this translation or not if you
want to use you know the new pinker translation
that's coming out or you want to use the miller
translation or the finlay translation more
power to you what i care about is people actually
reading the text because of these lectures
so we're going to do more of these next is
going to be the introduction then we're going
into consciousness in those three sections
i'm not sure how long it'll take but in any
case glad that you've come along this far
with me and we've got a lot of really exciting
vistas to to climb to and to look out over
the whole history of human consciousness from